from the High Street to Oak catcher
fashion is a 1.3 trillion dollar
industry but it comes with a hefty
environmental price tag cotton
production is being blamed for depleting
water sources and contaminating the
environment with pesticides chemical
waste from clothes manufacturing has
devastated rivers in Asia and some
estimates suggest the fashion industry
is on course to create a quarter of
projected global carbon emissions by
2050 if you take design a lot of it is
take make dispose there's another
looming threat for the fashion industry
and it's going to put clothing materials
under the microscope like never before
[Music]
this man is known as The Godfather of
microplastic research in fact professor
Richard Thompson invented the term
microplastics are basically just small
fragments of plastic that are
accumulating in the environment his
latest research has uncovered something
that has sent shock waves around the
fashion industry the data we collected
showed significant increase in the
quantities of micro plastic in the
environment a lot of what we found in
that study was plastic fibers
synthetic materials like polyester nylon
and acrylic are made of plastic fibers
these degrade and break up in a washing
machine cycle if we take a domestic
washing load that could release up to
700,000 fibers in a single wash now
that's going to go to wastewater
treatment some of those fibers will be
intercepted in wastewater treatment but
a good number will potentially escape to
the environment the data suggests that
they're accumulating year-on-year
between 2000 and 2016 the use of
polyester by the global garment industry
increased from 8 point 3 to 21 point 3
million tons annually a third of the
fish that I collect from a sample in the
English Channel near to here I've got
synthetic pieces in their guts in 10 20
30 years time the quantities in those
organisms is only going to be greater
the long-term effects of these plastics
in the food chain and even in humans are
still unknown but professor Thompson's
discovery is ringing alarm bells when I
talk to designers they tell me that you
know shedding of fibers and indeed
end-of-life recyclability was never part
of the design brief environmental
considerations like these are making
some fashion brands go back to the
drawing board
[Music]
Tom K has spent his life around the
ocean in 2003 he launched a brand that
creates functional and sustainable
products for those that share a love of
the sea
his company is experimenting with
different design processes in order to
lessen its environmental impact if you
take design a lot of it the minute is
take make dispose
that is totally unsustainable if we
really have to address the root of the
problem and that's really designing out
harmful fibers harmful fabrics harmful
processes the company use only organic
cotton it's developed a recycled
polyester insulation for jackets and has
created its very own wet suit recycling
program polymer polyester you can take
like long time time again finis tears
design team has also returned to one of
the oldest materials known to man
[Music]
we've been fake founder wolf since I
started it's a great fiber it's a
natural fiber it's biodegradable it's
fully traceable Finisterre is one of
2,700 beak or approved companies members
spanning many industries are assessed on
their environmental performance and have
a legally binding commitment to put
sustainability before profit it isn't a
done deal about 15 years to deliver this
it's mainly work every day to kind of
prove on and get better one designer is
turning fashions plastic problem on its
head Xavier go energy runs eco al he's
taking plastics out of the ocean and
turning them into shoes these nickers is
a result of more than two years of R&D
they're active all van comfortable all
the upper is made from 100% plastic
bottles from the bottom of the ocean the
outsole is made from algae and his shoes
rarely go through a washing cycle he's
limiting the plastic microfibers that
end up in the ocean eco Alf is creating
high-end fashion and household and
industrial waste sourced from fishermen
in the Mediterranean and Thailand
we started working with no three
fishermen of the east coast of Spain and
now we have nearly 3,000 fishermen
taking waste out of the ocean every day
over they can tolerate 250 tons which we
then convert into polymer yarn fabric
and profit but xavier is also pioneering
a new synthetic material made from
recycled plastic that doesn't shed
fibers in the same way as current
materials we started a project one year
ago which is within new yarn we're
kidding from the ocean we want to start
investing in how can we create a yarn
that doesn't throw microfilaments to the
system
xavier is one of a growing number of
boutique brands using recycled plastics
the way we do things are much more
complicated not only much more expensive
and at the end of the day is much easy
to go to a fabric show buy a fabric
produce a garment and sell it the sooner
bigger fashion labels and brands follow
suit the cheaper this environmentally
friendly clothing will become there are
few laws regulating the use of synthetic
materials in the fashion industry of
course I'm concerned about the natural
environment I'm a marine biologist that
works in marine habitats microplastics
are persistent and we know that they're
accumulating and we know that we're
finding marine life encountering them on
a regular basis more research is needed
into the potential harm caused by micro
plastics but their very presence in the
natural environment poses serious
concerns and challenges for the fashion
industry
can businesses accused of putting style
over substance get to grip with the
materials they're using and the impact
they may be having on the planet